we didn't want to have this poster of
values that nobody cares about
uh that are kind of the same for
everybody and
we could not relate to and instead of
kind of
forming values and then presenting and
then doing the hr thing of
of keeping them um um
informed and everything uh we actually
we built our story our culture together
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community community-driven vc fund in
silicon valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillary stanford leap and
birthright excel
and in media partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about
product all about product meet limo
segev vice president of product
at pecan limo is a proud mother of four
and very happily married
she has over 18 years of experience in
tech the last 11 years in product
management
in startups ebay and wework during her
career she was always attracted to data
and ways to leverage it to make a
business impact
her last two roles before joining pecan
were ebay where she led the product team
for the ebay catalog
and in wework billing and payments today
she leads product at pecan
with a mission to empower every data
analyst to create business
impact using machine learning and
predictive analytics
welcome to 20 minute leaders vice
president of product at pecan how are
you doing
oh good very very excited to be here
super uh
super excited thank you for now is it
pecan or pecan
because my israeli an american that's it
yeah
that's a great question i like pecan i
think that's the uh that's the right way
to go
uh and obviously we are kind of
addressing a lot of the u.s
market some still say
pecan go with pecan pecan it is and
uh vice president of product limo give
me the breakdown of
how you ended up vice president of the
product of this amazing amazing company
i had zohar
on the show just a few weeks ago which
which was marvelous and we talked a
little bit about the domain and the
vision and the vertical
and and predictive analytics now i'm
curious to dive deep into your own
journey and how
you as vp products are creating an
organizat are helping create an
organization that
strives for excellency
um yeah so uh the story has a lot to do
with daw actually um
i um i i joined uh
pecan uh before pecan i was i had a lot
of product uh
roles uh at ebay and then at wework and
then
uh the wework thing happened uh they
kind of
we had this uh moment when the
realization of this is uh not happening
uh
what's happening and it was a kind of a
a crisis for me
i had a very large group of people there
a lot of them i kind of tired myself i
kind of looked them in the eye and
promised them
that we are going to do amazing things
and then we had to let everybody
uh go which was obviously a personal um
crisis and and um and it was also
following these two years of super super
intense
work and i kind of announced to
everybody who knows me
that i'm not going to do anything
that is even remotely related to
startups i i need
i need to relax i need kind of i need my
time to get out i'm going to do
consultancy or just join in
an enterprise and now i just want to
give it a small spoiler
according at least to to the linkedin
page you were a vp product until march
of 2020 and we work vp product billing
and payments and you started
vp product at pecan uh about a month
later
that's that that's how did that happen
and uh yeah so a friend
who was kind of the data expert
at wework everybody was trying to
convince me that i'm
that i'm wrong that i just did the
market is amazing there's a lot of
opportunities
and i was kind of meeting a few people
just to be polite and i was like
no way not going to do anything that is
related to startups i need a break
and she she said you know what just do
it for me just meet
with the guy he's super nice uh and you
know
maybe maybe you will consult or
something like that and i saw i went to
middle
uh uh really really with kind of
no uh uh i didn't feel like it i was
kind of very involved with what's going
to happen with my people
and then two things happened in the
meeting that kind of changed everything
as you said
one um the dynamic uh with
with zor personally uh was amazing
and it was inspiring to see
this combination of a ceo who is both
visionary but super humble
and kind of and everybody knows that the
dynamic between vp
product and the ceo is something that
you need to address it can be complex
sometimes it can be sensitive
um and i kind of knew that that
we can make it happen that we can make
it work very
very well and the second thing is that
um while he was describing
what pecan is doing i could feel the
pain
i said well i i know this pain i was
sitting on a lot of data
not being able to realize value out of
it like i
i i was literally um kind of
seeing myself uh as a business owner
you know as a kind of you look more
holistically at my job at wework
we were owning uh billing we had a lot
of data related problems
and i said if i if i had that i could
be in a better place because we were
kind of begging for data scientists for
a year sitting on great data
um and so that was that was the second
thing i could
actually see and understand the pain
of having data having a lot of people
that know intuitively what to do with
the data but not having the data
scientist
that can help you realize uh and get
value out of it and to be quite
honest in some cases and
again work with a lot of data scientists
great people
uh but sometimes even if you have a data
scientist
the dynamic and the kind of
the pace is different uh between what
the stakeholders and the business need
and what sometimes
are the cycles in data science world so
i could actually see myself
enjoying pecan kind of realizing value
amazing and so
so that's the end of this uh i'm not
going to do startup story
and so as you're you're joining pecan
and you're formulating
your own conviction around the world
which sounds like in terms of you know
the professional side you
you understand the domain you felt that
you felt the need and you felt the pain
and and you're a part of solving it and
now you're you need to construct
a cohort an army to go in and tackle it
tell me a little bit about the values of
pecan and
how you and the management team thought
through honing in on those values
yeah i i like the way you phrase it
because it's exactly like that we needed
a group of super passionate people
because we are solving
hard problems like we are actually uh
solving uh
things that require a lot of passion and
a lot of effort
and a lot of smart people to uh to kind
of do
this crazy journey with us and um
when we kind of started uh talking about
uh
do we need values we're just a small
startup this is kind of uh
the big common company things and we we
were
we didn't want to have this poster of
values that nobody cares about
that are kind of the same for everybody
and we could not relate to
and but we did know that there is
something unique here
that as we grow we need to maintain and
as we grow we need to kind of
make sure that we are being true to what
we want to be
um and instead of kind of forming values
and then presenting and then
doing the hr thing of keeping them
um informed and everything
uh we actually we built
our story our culture together so we had
a
like few focus group uh everybody joined
everybody said
had to imagine how we want to be how we
are today where are the gaps
how do we want people who are joining uh
to act and to think and
uh i have to say that i love what we
came up with
i think it's a really true uh
representative of what we are
which is um ego aware
value devoted creative builders
but even putting the outcome aside for a
second the process
was amazing the process of asking each
and every employee
um who we are who do we want to be and
who do we want the people who are
joining us to be um
yeah and it was um it was this focus
group and then we did
uh some voting and refined it and we
find it
uh super super like it was an amazing uh
and so what that
what you mentioned before is that you're
not looking to just write a nice poster
that people don't actually
don't actually absorb how do you feel
that this process changed the way that
the employees are interacting with these
values
on a regular basis obviously they're not
meant to be chanting these values as
they roam the the halls of the company
but how but how does it change the way
that they're actually absorbing those
values
um in i think in three ways one is
it gives um everybody tools
to keep everybody's honest so if i'm
doing something that is
not cool or not aligned with how we want
to be
it sometimes it feels weird to just
say yes but if you have the values uh if
you can say you know what that's not
really being
so if somebody is really really uh stuck
in a specific idea or not willing to let
it go not
willing to kind of uh uh get other
opinions or try something else and
you you can see that he's already kind
of
um uh in this point where he wants to be
right
like being right is what he's trying to
get you can say you know what
i think uh this is not totally ego aware
maybe you should kind of reflect for a
second and
it's an easier way to do the
conversation or
it keeps uh it this it gives the
employee the
the way to uh sorry a tool to challenge
us
so if we want to engage with a
partnership
that the developers feel is wrong
they can say this is not value devoted
we cannot provide
value to this customer or to this
partnership and we shouldn't do that
and you cannot dismiss it if you just
actually agreed with them that this is
the value you have to
so this is one the second one is uh is
classic but still super critical
this is how we evaluate people who are
joining
um which is really really critical there
there's great people uh super talented
that might know how to do the job
and might be a great fit for a lot of
other companies
uh but if we feel that they will not be
able to live
based on those values then we kind of
uh we won't be able to uh um to recruit
them
and that calls out for tough decisions
with you know how they hire
how the market looks like from a talent
perspective and i have to say that i i'm
super proud of the team
of kind of keeping that incredible and
and i think the third one which is um
which is also important and we use it is
that this is a great way to do the
onboarding
this is a great way of someone joining
they they go through the value uh
training and everything and they talk to
people
but they also get a chance to contribute
to
them and they also get a chance to
actually say
this is uh how would i change it and
they also get a chance
to actually say are we actually living
according to that to those values um
yeah i think it's uh
it's uh those three things
uh and you know there's stuff like we do
we talk do we take use cases
see in cases that we feel that we didn't
leave by our values and actually
evaluate them
amazing um like on a day-to-day just
being tough and i think that you know
one of the most interesting things that
that will leave me also thinking after
this after this recording
and it's this idea of we give employees
a way to challenge the team
right this and this is not a trivial
statement uh
you know and as we're as we're moving
more towards the bottom up
world i i feel in the workforce
especially in in the tech world
and it's a very interesting idea of
empowering the employees to challenge
the team to challenge the company
decisions through a set of shared values
which i think is remarkable
now tell me a little bit also about your
stance on on product development in
general so you're vice president of
product
and one of the things that we briefly
talked about is is the ability to um
to provide ownership
and responsibility across all all
employees
across the entire value chain tell me
about that
um so if you take a step back and you
look at the beginning of the story of
why i joined pecan
um i joined um
somebody else's dream like there was two
people who already were was already
dreaming about
this amazing thing it was so amazing
that it made me join
and um when i joined i needed
a way to get connected to it
and but to also contribute to it in a
way that
um i i kind of keep the balance and
get them to kind of make me part of that
journey like
an authentic part of my journey but i
also knew that it's not about me it's
about
providing that to each and every
member of the team i it's like
imagine uh imagine you are asking
let's take kind of a a depressing
example for a second but i think
a good one let's say you you you there's
a war
and you want to get everybody to kind of
jump with
you it will be much easier if they know
why they are jumping
or even more so if they actually
were the one that defined why and
were the ones who that kind of defined
the target and
um so what what instead of kind of you
know
product world in in another way the
product process
you sit in a room you talk to a lot of
people separately you talk to
do all stakeholders and stuff and then
you come up with this
presentation the vision presentation and
you present it and everybody claps and
then we start running
and that's one way to do the process
another way to do the process
is to create a shared narrative
a shared pecan narrative of what
we want when we talked about the values
is who we want to be
when we're talking about the vision is
what we want to be for our customers
and so probably when i joined
i needed to hear a non-story
of let's take this uh two years
uh into the future and you have you
you receive this kind of excited email
from a customer
what what does it say what does it try
what do you what do you read inside
um so first of all each of their letters
was slightly different
so we were able to talk about that but
then we actually opened it up
we asked every employee to to write that
uh email to write that email what would
a satisfied
customer two years from now would say
what do they gain what is the value that
they are getting out of it
um and this first of all it's a fun
exercise to do like it's it's fun
writing
how a satisfied customer would uh
uh kind of react in two years is a fun
exercise the second thing
is that it will it enables us to share
the story in a very
kind of fun and judgmental way you
cannot judge what i'm dreaming about
dreaming about but we can compare it and
see if we are actually dreaming
uh the same thing and after that we did
a lot of work of you know
concising it and kind of uh refining it
into a short
shared narrative that we keep updating
but it's about
kind of everybody has its own part in
the story
i i love it limo it sounds like the
journey at pecan
is incredible and it sounds like the
intentionality behind building a
right culture one that is empowering the
idea of challenging thoughts
and and creating shared values and more
importantly aligning
the vision and the mission of everybody
towards what it means to me to build a
successful company an organization
i love that and i'm taking a lot of
lessons to myself in this so thank you
for the time
hey i want to spend the last couple
minutes going back and
talking a little bit more about you and
i'd like to go back to your childhood
and hear from you what really fascinated
you as a kid
well i was a geek from the get-go so i
loved math
uh i was really really um
kind of obsessed with it i loved it
from the guy like from very very early
age till high school
amazing boring and and what what
inspires you today
um so
if we talk about my personal life then
my kid is inspiring me every day
uh with their new ideas and new thoughts
and there's
something fresh about kind of kids uh
how they face um it's like you are able
to be
excited about snow or stuff like that
just through their
eyes and uh professionally
i'm super um kind of
excited about this movement of project
product
growth uh the fact that today
um it's this it's not the actual uh
pragmatics but it's the fact that you
are actually
creating product that people love and
creating products that people
actually uh gain value out of it so
again
geek again in that sense and what are
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
wow uh i would say
uh thoughtful uh
passionate and always willing to be
wrong
i love it limo it sounds like the
journey was
amazing and it's just beginning and and
i can't wait to follow pecan and sing
and see what happens but thank you for
taking the time to share with me i'm
leaving with a lot of
amazing insights and an amazing story so
thank you for that
and stay safe and stay healthy